basé est-ce qu'il ya des insurgés ici
demande lui valent un film raté les
évoquera taylor
il faut que les petits jobs aux
démocrates et aux loups de la méjane
hectares à roissy il dit que s'il parle
lui tranche la gorge dès le matin il dit
écoutez moi je sois en tout kolko vous
tous écouté mois les jo ackermann est-il
8 affirmé wendy c'est chez moi
talabani et 10 et mattel avait là bas
vous ne pouvez pas me faire partir la
tête haute je vais pas me faire passer
et vous ne pouvez pas faire partir les
monstres il moralement village sous la
terre avec la manger se tait ce maire
qui fassent la pluie en train de venir à
tanger
tu vas que des connards me touchent pas
que tu es malade qu'est ce que tu fous
de soleil
tu vois ce que choix
ok
bizot dénivelé